what you notice is this does borrow a
lot from like those simpler applications
where as they are or I need to combine
these in subway and for example the sum
of roots in this case all reciprocals
right requires you to them get them on a
common denominator so what does the
numerator end up looking like is it not
the sum of pairs right if you're going
to get alpha beta on alpha beta gamma
which gives you this right then you get
alpha gamma 1 alpha beta gamma will give
you this and then your last one gives
you all tan alpha right once you divide
through by alpha and gamma however you
notice that the sum of roots are two at
a time in here is CMA hey and what
you're dividing by is minus 3 on a right
so you've got that on a that's
cancelling so this in fact is actually
minus minus seen on d yes some of pairs
what happens when you add them all
together the end up with a very similar
fashion oh [ __ ] but again this is where
you begin right when you put together
all rest of them equal to this except on
the numerator you're going to get them
one more time right alpha + beta + gamma
all on ok because this is minus V on a
and that's my DNA you're just getting be
on d aren't you right last one the
easiest one okay when you multiply all
of them you're just getting that we
already know what alpha beta gamma is so
I just take the reciprocal which i think
is minus a on deep yeah you get it I
came through instead you can you can be
the punch line for us ok so I'm going to
take my one two three results I'm going
to supply them in here which gives me
minus
on a day be ordained and minus a date
and most of you realize this point oh
this looks from doing on I've got the
double negatives and I've also got this
numerator sorry denominator it's very
easy to get real so I'm just going to
multiply through right that should give
you this I think most people are happily
puts muscles have this point yeah
looking good it's very nice it's it's
it's perfect okay we can go a little bit
we can push a little bit further on it
and you want to give in yeah then you
fight everything by execute okay now i
am going to divide everything by execute
even though this is fine the reason why
is because i see the same thing i had
before like I've got them something
happening in reverse order right sort of
fix that up to make the oddest matchup
if i divide through my x cubed that's
just going home d that's going to be see
on x6 re be on x squared and a on X
cubed and now it's sort of jumping out
using it right do you see that if I pop
the order of background public this is
one on X cubed and then that looks a
little awkward but I'm just trying to
make the function notation more obvious
I've got this guy which is one on x
squared this guy which is one of X and
this one which is d this is not this is
not a cubic is ur not a cubic at least
in the way that I've rewritten it but it
is a cubic in and what in one that we
should not surprise us at all given the
way the questions started okay so you
take advantage of little things like
this it does relate a little bit too
when you're graphing when you're doing
we are doing the hydrographic extension
to you know I want is there what are the
relationships of the roots of this thing
to the roots of this thing right like
visually what does look like and the
answer is whatever is amiss are this
will have the reciprocals of all
okay as it's really simple any questions
yeah but will baby meet a girl like oh
that our first degree and then one of
Venus the next room and then through
downloads in theory they can do anything
they like in practice if these things
are too different from one another it
becomes just an algebraic disaster to
get anywhere because of them because of
the packing this to it and the fact that
this relates directly to the graphing
topic that's why it ends up all coming
up so beautifully in the watch right so
I would read that a very very low chance
but the fact that we can go through this
and a panda we didn't know anything
about this to begin you right through
the other it came out in theory you
should be able to play repeating the
explanation you mean just here to make
sure i get so will you okay up to this
point so the reason we divided through
by x cubed which to try and get the
order of these coefficients to match up
to what originally happened because my
order was backwards right so that's why
i divined it through and then in this
case here it's not quite as obvious
because i'm under water evaporates and
number two I want to show this is a
polynomial in 1 and X right so that's
why I separated out the 1 and X cubed
right there separate out the one they
squared right there and so on and so
this looks identical to what I started
with accept all my exes have been
replaced with 10 mixes so that's why I
can say this okay just like if I
evaluated I'd say are all the excellent
replace my twos that's what the function
notation means so I'm just replaced with